i thought the last 30 days of high  school senior year last 30 days was the  weirdest phenomenon which was everyone  was in their cliques and out of nowhere  after three  and seven eighth years of everyone  living in their own worlds everyone kind  of came together  and intermingled i remember that too  actually everyone's coming together at  the end i watched it consistently when i  got into high school the three grades  above me and i had two younger siblings  it happened for them i stayed very close  to this concept i used to have this  movie titled the last 30 days and it was  the last 30 days of high school i i i'm  probably gonna make it yeah